Karine cherche un appartement à louer
une annonce attire son attention
magnifique 4 et demi en plein cœur de
Montréal chauffage inclus pour 700
dollars par mois mais elle flère un
vieux piège dans lequel tomb encore bien
des gens le supposé propriétaire tente
de l'embobiner il lui dit qu'il est à
l'étranger il veut louer rapidement d'où
le loyer si bas mais avant de visiter ce
superbe logement il faudrait qu'elle lui
envoie tout de suite 700 dollars par
transfert d'argent Karine n'est pas naï
elle sait très bien le premier loyer
uniquement après avoir visité
l'appartement et signé un bail avec une
vraie personne le fin mot de l'histoire
les frudeurs vivent au dépend de ceux
qui les écoutent qu c'est trop beau des
[Musique]
doutes